[Music]
[Applause]
all right
he's uh actor uh jamie hector he's in
one of my favorite shows
i've been talking about bosch for well
what seven years now
since day one uh titus weliver is the uh
uh the the lead of this but uh jamie
plays his
sidekick uh jay edgar jerry edgar who
joins us on the program congrats on the
success of the show there
uh jamie uh how surprised were you with
the success of this
thank you dan um thanks for having me by
the way
surprise you know we were it was
amazing to us because we were the first
show on amazon to
actually set amazon off on this this
this platform of viewership right people
actually sitting and watching
amazon as a television show and then to
see the success the longest running show
on amazon it just
it blew my mind so how surprised was i
with michael connolly and eric overmay
are on board i was um
i was i was i was not surprised that it
was great because i know that they're
writing and their casting was going to
be
on point but i was just happy that we
lasted this long ever get really mad
at bosch or vice versa like titus you
and titus went when you're filming did
you ever get really
angry meaning the two of us personally
in our real life where you mean harry
and j ed well i know harry and jay edgar
you guys have a real problem in season
seven but
uh have you and titus had
no no no no no we never had an argument
about anything actually you know we get
along really well we're both from the
east coast
um respected each other's work before we
came on board and
um we approached the work similar in
similar fashion so we enjoyed working
around each other we just always can't
wait to get him back to work
with understanding right we we've been
doing this for seven seasons
so every year we were ready to come back
to work with each other
and this year things are changing
meaning going into next year but
no no never any conflict or anything at
all
yeah and then i started to wonder about
this when you immerse yourself in a role
so when you're playing a cop that you
probably have to
hang out with cops do you look at cops
differently
now having played a cop well i
do well you know i look at good cops
the same as i've always looked at them
you know what i mean
people that are dedicated to doing the
work people that are dedicated to
supporting and protecting and serving
right and you're a good cop
on bosch right would you say you're a
good comp i mean i i do the work
you try you try to be able to try yeah
absolutely i come and i try to do
the work that is to
a perfect example you've seen the season
right it's first season was we were
trying to capture a necrophiliac
i'm sure everybody wants that guy off
the street um
and that's our job to make sure that the
civilians the citizens are protected
and we come out there to serve them so
yeah i consider myself a good cop
absolutely but but did you do driver
drive alongs with the cops when you were
researching this yeah i did you know
what
i'm from new york so i've done driving
alongs with my partners here in new york
uh
todd butler um and then when i went to
la
i've done drive arounds with tim marsha
and
mitzi robertson and um it was an amazing
adventure right because we drove all
around l.a
went to watts went to um inglewood
and then made it back to beverly hills
and that's when the drama started that's
when we had to jump out
and tim actually had to go and address
an individual that was assaulting his
wife
well then it gets real and then like so
do you stay in the car
you know what i stay in the car but
there was one incident out here in new
york where
we went on a raid and there was a guy
that was
selling guns out of his home he was from
north carolina and
they told me we met at six o'clock in
the morning and they said listen
you can stay in the car or you can come
inside i was like what's up with the
bulletproof vest
i mean this was in bushwick brooklyn
right
and yeah so i was like hold on a second
so you guys are allowing me to come into
the house so they let me go in i went in
no gun
no vest of course i wouldn't have a gun
but they were certain that
it was safe some of them climbed the
fence
some walked through the door i walked
through the door and then we scouted the
entire apartment
and it was really interesting because
the guy got wind that they were coming
and he took off
i wonder though if somebody's going to
see you and think it's marlow from the
wire
meaning oh you're meaning like on the on
the raid yeah yeah yeah hey marlo
yeah no i experienced that i did i
experienced that going driving in um
in inglewood it was like milo
are you more likely to have somebody ask
you a question about the wire
or bosch when you when somebody
recognizes you
you know what it's it's a combination of
both now because
i'll base it on the new york knicks
right the madison square guard
i would always go there to go watch the
game
and my first two or three seasons
of working on um bosch
whenever i walk through the stadium
everyone would be
screaming out marlo marlo stanfield why
oh my god let's do this take a picture
but then after the third season four
five six whenever i went back to a game
that it just changed for some reason
everyone was screaming jerry edgar
for the most part people were really
loving the show when they were
approaching me based on that
so it's a fine balance right now they
really love the work
in the show uh paulie my producer has a
question but he wants to know if you'll
answer this
as marlo okay can you are you capable
no let me tap back in hold on i need a
minute
of course okay i just want to make sure
i you know i just
yeah okay all right paulie your question
for
for uh for jamie as marla if you're a
fan of the wire like most of us are
okay i guess maybe either marlo or your
character when you had to kill prop
joe what was going through your mind
prop joe is one the big drug dealer on
the oh yeah very lovable very beloved by
the fans
so this is not his jamie actually this
is his marlo yeah maybe ball through
marlo's mind yeah all right
well what was going through through his
mind i would have to say was
his purpose
on earth has expired
it was done and and looking at him and
the way he took care of himself the way
that he took care of his community
meaning himself physicality-wise and
just his inability to control his people
anymore it was just
time for somebody to remove that crown
and that's what marlo was constantly
chasing which was
power and um and prob joe had it
how far ahead did you get in the wire
that you knew what was going to happen
well we received a script
with unlike today which we're binge
watching right
yeah so we i'm working on a project
right now for hbo and i already got all
the scripts
so i know what's going to happen
beginning to end
but working on the wire it was per
episode so i didn't know
which one do you prefer i prefer
it doesn't really make a difference to
me i mean like um because
when it's a screenplay a film
i get the entire script and i enjoy it i
know the beginning to end but
i approach it the way i approach it but
so for me it doesn't make a difference i
prefer both whichever one works best you
know but
but i have to say i enjoy reading
everything and knowing what's
going on from beginning to end so i
would prefer that
and you know a lot of the stars in the
wire they were english
like when they came over just trying to
immerse themselves in baltimore in that
culture
i yeah i how i guess even more
challenging
for those guys to be able to do that
what did you think though when you
these guys would have their english
accent and then all of a sudden they
would go into their dialogue in the wire
and you're like
they transformed themselves into
stringer bell i would just say dag
this dude is talented idris
dominic west even my guy that played the
mayor karceti
i would just look at them and just um
respect
their level of dedication you know
because
once the cameras are off they're back
into there
they might and i'm like oh man i like
that
but you're young at the time i mean
you're really new to this business
i'm new to the business but in regards
to training and just knowing what it
takes to actually do what
is to be done i wasn't new to that so i
knew that it took a certain amount of
level of discipline
consistency and dedication to get there
you know
um who scared you what character scared
you on
made you a little nervous on the wire
what characters made me a little nervous
me
jamie hector yeah or okay
the character that made me nervous on
the wire
was um snoop seemed real
no snoop was real right snoop is real
but
the character that scared me was
um
isaiah whitlock she
[Laughter]
no a person that you can't trap in the
corner he's the only one that you
can't trap in the corner he can make he
can destroy
he can build he can just he can just
dismantle you
and he knows how to sell light bulbs
you know remember that scene where he he
told string a bell like look man i'm
giving you a deal man a deal
you know you're going to put up all
these light bulbs in the entire board of
education
that's that's a dude that you got to
look out for he's scared
he was so good so good as a politician
uh we're talking to jamie hector he
plays uh like got a variety of roles but
uh he was jay edgar in the
seventh and final season of bosh no
spoiler alert here
but i do think we're going to see a
spin-off will you be involved in the
spin-off
with well i'm not sure yet i wasn't
given the word
but um i'm looking forward to seeing it
you no you're being coy there's no they
don't know
no there is a spin-off but i'm not too
sure where i stand in the spin-offs
yeah cause there's i got some questions
still left for your character i don't
think we wrapped everything up in season
seven there
oh yeah yeah you got some issues still
going on there chad
i mean they don't just go away right
especially no
and by the way if you if you haven't
seen bosh bosh has this unbelievable
crib
it's it's spectacular and uh he's always
got jazz playing
and uh you know his his daughter maddie
but have you been in
to uh to harry's crib there in the
wherever that is in the hills yeah no i
have i have um
on i think it's season four right i went
to visit him in regards to somebody that
shot his wife so i brought some
information to him over there
and then um on one or two occasions then
it was a shootout that came to
assassinate him over there and then
myself and
um robertson we went over there to go
and help him out so yeah on several
occasions
i uh i realized that you were in he got
game not a big role
so i had to go back and see if i could
find you and he got gained you i think
you had
two lines and he got game hey jesus i
love you jesus
i love you jesus jesus can you help me
out with some money man come on what's
up man
yeah yeah oh yeah i didn't forget that
was
spike lee came listen i'm in um
unholding and i'm like man this is how
they treat the x-rays and holding it was
just one apple right
i'm standing over there and then spike
comes and he just looks and he's
like choose him and him
and i was like what am i doing and then
he he basically gave me those lines he
said i need you to come over here
and just tell this dude how much you
love him basically you're like a leech
trying to leech on a basketball player
that just found new success
and money and i'm that guy that's over
there just begging him for money you
know
and yeah i was excited do you tell your
family you're in a movie with denzel
washington
yeah you got that right
oh you know that's right look mom i'm
i'm i'm here with denzel
[Laughter]
he's got a few more lines than i do mom
but you know
a bigger part you know but i'm dead tell
me about the
non-profit theater uh that you uh the
organization you have there before we
say goodbye man
absolutely absolutely organization then
did in my heart started in 2007's called
moving mountains
so we we develop skills talents and
abilities
in youth while building character
purpose
because there's not enough of it in our
community one
two it's just um something i was done
for myself growing up also and i feel
like you know
if they have the access the opportunity
then
they can be great and i would just get
out there wearing a lot and be great
that's awesome uh omar coming
whoa why
not anymore not omar not god i love that
character
omar i'm trying to tell you yeah yeah
yeah i'm all coming
[Laughter]
i'm not even gonna do it mike because i
know that's you but no
farmer in the dell i think is what he
would whistle right
farmer dale yeah amazing character
amazing role yep
yeah you did not want omar coming you
did not you didn't want to hear that
no you didn't uh jamie uh congrats on
your success i loved bosh
and uh hopefully titus uh finds a role
for you in the uh
this spin-off here oh man thank you so
much man i'm excited we're working right
now
currently i'm actually headed off to
work in baltimore on a project called we
own the city
also so that's gonna be hbo so that's
gonna be pretty cool
awesome thank you you're welcome thank
you brother jamie hector actor
uh he played marlowe on the wire plays
detective j
edgar on bosch